les secrets des couleurs ne le sont plus
pour ces jeunes peintres en herbe ses
enfants explorent depuis lundi cet
univers artistiques et scientifiques
vers la fin il me demande de regarder
les couleurs contre mélanger avec les
couleurs primaires
moi ce que j'ai trouvé c'est vert orange
et violet est en train de mélanger des
couleurs primaires avec les secondaires
et on a mélangé le jaune avec leur
hausse
ça fait du orange
après le plus avec le jaune du vert
animé par l'artiste plasticienne en
résidence ma flow est pas doué ce stage
est inscrit dans le programme estival de
la commanderie
un rendez vous destiné aux enfants de 6
à 17 ans on est quatre ans mission
installer ici
et l'idée c'est qu'on propose aussi au
public de traverser tous les genres
qu'on défend à la commanderie
les enfants sont vraiment en immersion
et c'est ce qui nous intéresse aussi
dans ce projet de c'est les vacances
c'est que les enfants soient en
immersion toute la journée avec
l'artiste avec l'intervenant est avec
ses petits copains de l'atelier autres
salles de stage et autre ambiance ici
les jeunes se transforment en
scientifique il découvre que
l'électricité ce n'est pas que de la
magie je compte essayer de leur faire
fabriquer un condensateur pouvoir
réaliser des petites étincelles avec un
condensateur
pourquoi pas on va travailler sur un
système de
de transmission de son par laser l'idée
c'est de transmettre le son grâce à du
laser et grâce à la lumière en général
jusqu'au 31 juillet dix ateliers sont
programmés au sein de la commanderie de
la danse de la nature et de la lecture